لاجئ حرب رست سفينته في هونج كونج وبدا
منها رحله شاقه كبائع احزمه بلاستيكيه ثم
اصبح رجلا خارقا يسيطر على الاسواق
والعقارات والمرافق المهمه ليس فقط في
هونج كونج بل وفي العديد من دول العالم
انه لكاشنج الذي استخدم سته الاف وخمسمائه
دولار ليبني ثروه تقدر بسبعه وثلاثين
مليارا ومئه مليون دولار فما سر هذه
الثروه ولد ليكاشينغ عام
1928 في مقاطعه الصينيه وكان والده مديرا
لمدرسه قبل ان يقع الغزو الياباني للصين
في عام 1940 وهو ما دفع العائله للفرار
الى هونغ كونغ في غضون ثلاث سنوات من
وصولهم الى هونج كونج توفي والده فوقع على
المراهق لي حمل كبير في اعاله الاسره عمل
لي في شركه للتجاره البلاس وكان دوامه
يمتد لنحو سته عشره ساعه يوميا حيث كان
يبيع احزمه البلاستيك لكن طموحه كان اكبر
من ذلك بكثير ففكر بان يبدا عمله الخاص في
وقت مبكر في عام 1950 كانت لدى لي خبره
معقوله حول عمل المصانع فجمع سته الاف
وخمسمائه دولار بعضها من مدخراته والاخر
استدانه من اسرته ليؤسس شركه لتصنيع
البلاستيك ومنحها
لي افضل الفنيين بصناعه الزهور
البلاستيكيه ثم اعد المصنع لزياره اول
مشتري اجنبي كبير انتهت الزياره بطلب
المشتري كميه كبيره لتبدا مسيره لي كبائع
دولي للزهور المصنعه ثم اصبح بعد بضع
سنوات اكبر موردا للزهور البلاستيكيه في
اسيا لتطوير عمله اشترى لي قطعه ارض لبناء
مصنعه بعد ان ادرك ان الاي التي ستستمر في
الارتفاع وهذا ما قاده للتفكير في
الاستثمار العقاري لكن الفكره تتاخرت حتى
عام
1967 حيث استغل فتره اعمال الشغب التي
عاشتها البلاد واشترى عددا من الاراضي
باسعار مخفضه ليؤسس شركه تشونغ هولدينج
للتطوير العقاري التي قام بادراجها في
بورصه هونج كونج للاوراق الماليه في عام
1958 اراد لي ان يجعل شركته الاكبر بمجال
تطوير العقارات فدخل عطاءات كبرى كمواقع
التطوير فوق محطتي سنترال وادمرت تي ام تي
ار في عام
1977 ما جعله المطور العقاري رقم واحد في
هونج كونج كما كان بطلا للعديد من الصفقات
الكبرى كبيع احد مبانيه في هونج كونج بما
قيمته 40 مليارا و200 مليون دولار في اطار
اكبر صفقه بيع للعقارات المكتبيه بمنطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ ما باع مجمع
السينشيلينج في شنغهاي مقابل مليارين
وخمسه وتسعين مليون دولار في صفقه اعتبرت
ثانيه اكبر صفقه بيع لمبنى واحد عمل لي
على توسيع نفوذه العقاري بالاستحواذ على
شركه
من مرافق موانئ الحاويات العالميه خاصه في
هونج كونج وكندا والصين والمملكه المتحده
وبعض البلدان الناميه الاخرى خلال السنوات
الماضيه استمر لي في توسيع اعماله فضم
ايضا الطاقه والاتصالات وتجاره التجزئه
وتشغيل الحانات وتاجير الطائرات ومع دخول
عصر رقمنه وجد لي ان البقاء والاستمراريه
يتطلبان التوجه نحو الاستثمار في مسارات
العالم الجديد فدعم مشروعات تكنولوجيه عده
واشترى حصصا بموقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فيسبوك في عام 2018 وبعد نحو واربعين عاما
على توليه منصب رئيس مجلس الاداره تنحى
ليصبح كبير المستشارين لشركتي
اراد لي من مجموعته ان تكون كنهر الذي
يتدفق عبر الصين ويجمع عددا لا يحصى من
الجداول والروافد حتى بات يوكنى شعبيا
بالسوبرمان فبعد ان كان مراهقا يتيما يعيل
اسرته اصبح رائد اعمال واغنى رجل في هونغ
كونغ